We are honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science and Plant and soil
sciences, doctor of veterary medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, bachelor
of science and plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical.
>> Hello and welcome everyone. So sorry for
the delays. Technology is amazing except
when it doesn't want to cooperate.
Today's one of those days we want to
throw it out the window and let it get
hit by a m truck. Anyway, um, welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I am so glad that
you are joining us today because we have
an amazing speaker, Adrien Gold. She is
going to be talking about am I
um toxins and our bodies and how they're
affected uh how our body is affected by
toxins. Also, um this program is
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
and if somebody referred you to this
program, please make sure to get back
with them as they are going to be your
main point of contact.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is intend not intended
to diagnose, treat or prevent any
diseases. nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results may vary and are
not typical. We do not make claims for
um regarding health, income or anything
else. As an empowered individual, you
have options available. So, I am going
to go ahead and bring our guest on since
we started late. And again, I apologize.
Like I said, technology just sometimes
has a mind of its own and
we're at its mercy.
>> Welcome, Adrian. You're looking gorgeous
today. So,
>> thank you. I was gonna say the same
about you.
>> Thank you.
>> So, thank you so much for putting up
with all this crazy and uh welcome
everyone. We're going to talk about how
to manage in our dirty world and I talk
fast so we will definitely make up the
time.
>> Okay.
>> All right. I'm just gonna let you take
over.
>> Thank you.
>> You are so welcome.
>> Um I think the biggest issue today is
how do we manage in our polluted world
and what is that doing to us and in
reality is if we could all
go back Um, I I've been saying this
phrase for a while now. I think we need
to go backwards to go forwards
in in in respect to our food and our
pollution. And since the genie's out of
the bottle, and I highly doubt we're
going to be going back to 4G or 3G,
um, organic regenerative farming for
everyone, um,
reducing the GMOs and going backward. I
don't see that happening. So what we
have to do is we have to wear the body
armor. We have to protect ourselves.
So how do we do that and what is it
affecting? Well, managing through this
dirty world so to speak affects our
weight, affects our brain function,
affects our energy levels, uh our focus
and attention,
uh our stamina and our longevity. What
can we do about it? Well, one of the
biggest two things that are affecting
most people are weight and brain health.
We have amazing amounts of dementia and
Alzheimer's coming down the pike. We
have unbelievable increases in autism on
the other end of the age spectrum. And
we have so many people who are
overweight and they're eating even
though they're eating healthy. So they
think they're something's blocking.
So let's talk about what we can do to go
backwards. Is there any food source we
can use on this planet to get us
backwards? Yes. Doc Walt's been talking
about the deficiency in minerals in the
soil forever. And I'm going to talk a
little bit about that as well in
slightly different way which is in the
form of pollen. Pollen is what creates
all plant life. If we could find a way
to eat the pollen before our world
ruined it all, that would be very, very
beneficial. And at Youngevity, we are
pretty much the only company anywhere
that actually has organic Swedish flower
pollen in tablets and in drink.
And this is this product, this product
line with Youngevity, which has been
with YJVevity for almost 20 years now,
is the way to go backwards to go
forwards. Eat your food before it had a
chance to grow. I know that sounds
counterintuitive, but think about what's
happening to your food when it grows.
We genetically modify it right out the
gate. We spray it with pesticides. We
plant it in demineralized soil like Doc
Wall has always been telling us. Then we
grow it. Then we pick it early. We spray
it with these weird chemicals to have it
ripen at a certain rate. Uh, and now the
ripening is getting too quickly. So by
the time you get your organic fruits and
vegetables to your home, they're nearly
dead.
Like I said, this is how you go
backwards to go forwards. You are
ingesting one packet of this a day,
maybe two. You are finally eating a meal
that was meant to be a meal that hasn't
been alterated or hasn't been
genetically modified or sprayed with
pesticides. You're eating food before we
had a chance to ruin it. Now, I know
Ruth Allen has possibly a slide or a
photo of what is in pollen. like it
seems like it's really tiny and you know
this bag of Palmer you know has some B
vitamins in it and it has you know extra
vitamin D and vitamin A and it has
something called pollen and SOD like
what is that? Um pollen has thousands of
nutrients in a tiny little grain and by
ingesting the pollen extracts at
longevity you're getting all of your
food nutrition. You're getting vitamins,
minerals, amino acids, fatty acids,
caronoids, flavonoids, all your enzymes,
all in a tiny little grain of pollen.
And in a way that your body recognizes
that pure food.
In addition to the pollen, if that
wasn't good enough, we added something
else that our bodies are constantly
losing as we're aging and getting
insulted by this polluted world, which
is SOD, super oxide disysmmitase. We are
the only company in the world that has
this combination of flower pollen and
SOD to put right back into the body. SOD
is your natural soldiers. It fights
aging, inflammation.
It helps the body take out the trash.
When your body is unable to take out the
trash on a regular basis, that trash
becomes cancer.
It becomes buildup and plaque in your
arteries and heart.
It becomes neurological blockages in
your brain. We don't want that. We need
to take out the trash. So the pollen
will feed you and the SOD micronutrient
antioxidant will help with the
inflammation in the body and help the
body do its own cleaning. And we need a
lot of cleaning. When I used to teach on
this 25 years ago,
uh pollen, the tablets, all we had were
the tablets. We didn't even have the
drape. My late husband, Dr. Cory uh was
brilliant in in helping that creation of
taking those wonderful tablets and
making them much more exciting, much
more powerful into a drink. So we have
the drink available, we have the pills
available, we it's basically your meal
for the day. And why it's important
uh
>> share the graphic now if that's
>> we're not we're not
>> Do you want me to share the graphic now?
So, we're not getting the food anymore.
We need real food. And this uh Thank
you. This is the nutrition the nutrition
profile of one grain of pollen. And this
is only part of it. We ran we ran out of
space on the page and there's thousands
of nutrients, but this is just an
example of 187 of them. And you can see
the categories, the vitamins, the
minerals, the caroids. We talked about
all the enzymes. There's like there's
like two columns of enzymes, lipids,
phytosteriles, all the stuff you're
getting in the purple foods that you're
supposed to be eating. All of the I mean
everything's in here.
Now, yes, those ingredients are also in
the liver tabs. And this is very
important because this one bottle helps
with really really body armor for this
polluted world. This does a good amount,
but this product has SOD and glut
glutathione.
And when I started teaching on this 25
years ago, nobody knew what glutathione
even was or how to spell it. They'd get
confused. Their eyes would roll back in
their head. What is this? Now,
glutathione is everywhere. People know
about it. People go to the local spa to
get an IV of glutathione and vitamin C
when they're going through chemo, where
they've just ran an Iron Man race, when
they're overcoming a long illness or
COVID. This is what they take. It's
people know about it now. So, you can
talk to them and say this is the only
product in the world that has the flower
pollen and the SOD
and the glutathione. It's a triple gift
here and nobody should be without this.
Um, people love this because it's easy.
Our lives are complicated. We are busy
as heck. We don't have time many times
to fast for two days, prepare 30
different tablets and pills, drinks six
times a day that uh that tastes like
mud, and feel like hor, you know, live
live in the bathroom for two days, take
time off work. That's a perfect detox,
but nobody has time or energy or
wherewithal to do it. But everybody can
do this. They can take two pills twice a
day. Done. They can drink their pollen
burst in the morning. They can take
their pollen tabs in the afternoon.
And this is body armor. And you know, 25
years ago, these products were so cool
to have and people love them. Today,
they're absolutely necessary.
We can't live without them. I hate to
say it. I wish I didn't have to say it.
Back in the day, these were kind of
added. Eat right and take your pollen.
Right now, eating right is taking your
pollen. Our food is dead. Even I shop
organic only. And even when I get my
organic fruits and vegetables home, they
die quickly because they've been sitting
for a while. And even at the farmers
market, it's harder. But not everybody
has access. I live in Southern
California in an ocean community where
there I can throw a stone and find a
farmers market. But not everybody can do
that. And farmers markets don't always
have everything you want either.
So aside from growing your own food,
this is the next best thing to growing
your own food. This is the next best
thing to going into a hospital setting
to get a glutathione drip and sit in an
infrared sauna. Uh so and it's easy to
do and it's not expensive to do. And in
addition to this being your body armor,
it's also amazing for anti-aging
and weight loss. Now, in my family in
particular, everyone talks about, "Oh, I
have bad jeans and I can't." Yes, you
can. I have jeans in my family for early
aging, early gray. Oh, by the way, this
is how much gray I have. Six months.
This is six months with the gray. I do
color my hair once every 12 months.
Okay. How many women color their hair
once every 12 months? That's how slow my
gray comes in because of this.
I don't have as many wrinkles as I
should have at age 62 based on my
genetics. My weight is probably a little
bit below normal, which is actually
great for um
a little bit under normal is actually
best for your organs.
Not leaning toward eating disorder area.
That's a whole different topic, but if
you're slightly underweight or at your
good weight, it's healthier for your
organs and your brain. I have obesity
running in my family, diabetes, early
aging, early gray, the whole shebang.
So, don't let your genetics
tell you what you need to have.
Um, 25 years on pollen. Look how much
hair I have. I have a ton of hair. And
now I messed it all up. So, it looks
crazy. But I'm saying this because I'm
62 and I have too much hair. This is
telling me that my body now hair I'm
making a note of this because hair is a
non-essential. If you are struggling in
your body, the first thing that's going
to go is your hair because it's
non-essential processes. Your body will
try
to save itself and it has if it doesn't
have enough energy to do the basics,
it's going to let the hair go. It's
going to let your joints go. It's going
to let your eyesight go. And it's going
to let your skin go because it needs to
protect your heart, your organs, your
digestion. That's most important. So,
this is just an example of 25 years on
pollen. And a lot of you at Youngevity,
a lot of you on the call have been with
us for this long and have been on the
pollen products and can see it. It's not
just me. Um, I've worked with kids with
brain and learning disabilities. I've
worked with people with chronic injuries
and gut issues and uh brain issues. And
this is so healing because it's simple
and it's basically like I said right at
the beginning, we have to go backwards
to go forwards
and go back to the food the way it was
supposed to be. So for weight loss, so
you're so excited you're going to get
all these products because it's good for
anti-aging. It's also great for weight
loss because this little bottle of liver
tabs will help your liver work faster.
It will get the toxins out quicker. And
if you want to find out why you still
have belly fat, that you're eating
healthy, you're exercising, you're doing
the 90 for life, you are doing your fish
oils, you're doing everything right,
you're eating good, healthy food, you're
watching your portions, and you can't
get rid of the belly fat no matter what.
This is the liver caps. This is your
liver slowing down. And when your liver
is slowing down, whether you've had too
many toxins, too much alcohol, living
near a freeway, um, or just genetically
unable to detoxify
on a regular basis, which is a
condition, I have it. It's called MTHFR
and it is methylation issues where your
body doesn't clear your toxins as
quickly as other people. So for me, 25
years ago, this was a godsend that I
didn't even know I did. And I think it
saved my life. I'm very sensitive to
heavy metals. I'm the one who can smell
a gas leak from a in a business weeks
before anybody else smells it. Um I'm
very sensitive to toxins. If I go to the
dental office and get a filling the next
day in the shower, I will smell dental
office smell like my body is getting rid
of it right away because of this. If I
didn't have it, it would stick in. Okay,
a lot of people have a genetic
predisposition for that. And anybody who
has any children or young adults on the
spectrum will most likely also have
MTHFR. Which is why when I started
working with children on the spectrum 25
years ago, this woke them up, gave them
eye contact, they could focus better,
they could speak, they could
communicate. And I didn't even know why
it was working. 25 years ago, I didn't
know that glutathione pulls out heavy
metals.
and that and the heavy metals were
affecting these kids who couldn't
detoxify on their own. Adults have it,
too. A lot of people have it. So, this
is just a testament to even me, someone
who has trouble detoxifying. This saved
me. And it it's it's it's a savior for
so many people. And back to the weight
loss, you have belly fat for a reason.
If you're doing all the right stuff and
you're not losing weight in your abdomen
area, your body is actually protecting
you. When your liver is slowing down,
whether it's from genetic
predisposition, sluggish liver, why are
all people getting fatty liver all of a
sudden? It's our pollution, right?
Everybody needs to be on liver tabs
because when your liver slows down, you
get a a backlog of toxins. And your
backlog has to sit somewhere. The safest
place for your backlog is in your belly
fat. fat will surround it, hold it,
protect it so that it doesn't get to
your brain, your heart, and other organs
and poison you. So, your belly fat is
actually saving you. The only way to get
rid of it or one of the only ways to get
rid of it and get off this plateau that
people hit is reduce your toxic load.
And by the way, sure, some people can't
move their home away from the freeway
off-ramp. They can't not paint their
house from time to time. They can't not
go to the dental office, right? What do
they do? Well, they clean up every day
with the liver tabs so that their body
is cleaner.
Their liver is working faster.
Glutathione is a direct vitamin to your
liver. When your liver works faster,
it can get to the waiting room in the
backlog and then it starts eliminating
the toxins in your fat and your fat will
then say to you, "I don't need to be
here anymore. I'm I'm good. There's no
reason." So now that you're eating
healthy, you're watching your sugar,
you're exercising, you're watching your
portions, now you add the liver tag, and
now
the rest of the melting will happen.
It's not about how fast you can go on
the treadmill.
It's not about how low your caloric
intake is or how much you're fasting.
It's colverse liver taps.
And of course, this is also great for
weight loss because it's a meal. We
talked about it and we saw the
screenshot of how many nutrients that
there's more nutrients in a packet of
polymers than there is in your salad,
your burger, your lunch, your dinner,
whatever it is. And
it it it's it's unfortunate that I have
to say that in this day and age, but
it's true.
This is a perfect meal. People have one
for breakfast. You can still eat. Have a
banana, have an orange, have a couple
eggs, and drink your pollen burst. It's
okay. You'll need extra protein. There's
no protein in the pollen burst. Tiny
tiny tiny bits. So, you know what I do
is I drink my burst every morning with a
scoop of our wonderful longevity
collagen. I get some protein in there
and good for your joints. And the berry
flavored, tropical berry flavored
collagen tastes great in the berry or
the orange pollen burst. Then you don't
think about it. You just throw it in
there. Done.
So, I'm not encouraging you not to eat.
Got to eat. You got to watch your food.
Um, one other thing we need to talk
about is the oils.
We need to separate the bad fats and
bring in the good fats. Replacement.
Replace your bad fats with good fats.
We're talking about omega-3. Um,
it's important to have all your omegas.
693, the whole shebang. But we are to
get too much six and nine daily living.
We're eating our flax on our cereal.
It's easy to get. It's in baked goods.
It's everywhere. We are having our u
inflammatory oils all over the place.
But omega-3, unless you're eating
sardines and salmon six days a week,
you're not getting your omega-3. And
there's the problem with that. years ago
when I would train on this, I would just
say for those of you who are eating
salmon and sardines six days a week,
you're good. Or five days, you're good.
Now, I'm going to tell you, you don't
even want to do that because unless you
can control your farm salmon and what
they're feeding the farm salmon could be
omega6. So, instead of getting an
omega-3 fish, you're getting an omega-6
fish. or if you let them grow in the
wild and you eat wild salmon, you're
getting mercury, PCBs, plastics, etc.,
etc., etc. So, we're kind of stuck,
right? So, and it it's I I don't mean to
ruin your day about the food, but eat
your food, but take your fish oils. This
is the cleanest fish oil you're going to
get. Koba Omega, it's been tried and
tested for the removal of all the
toxins, the mercury, and all the PCBs
and plastics and all that. It's clean.
It's non fishy. it won't repeat on you
is basically your insurance
because now we're stuck between farm
salmon and wild salmon that's eating
what's in our ocean and we're kind of
stuck. So enjoy your salmon however you
get it but take four to six of these
Poba omegas every day. Um most people
who complain about fish oils repeating
on them love the Poba Omega. It's one of
the bestselling omegas we have for a
reason. It won't remind you later that
you took it. I take two pills three
times a day. So, I'm trying to ward off
inflammatory issues like arthritis, eye
health, brain health. Um, so I take
three I take two pills three times a day
with meal.
And you maybe start with four and work
up, you know, and it's great for weight
loss. So, when you run out there and you
say, "I need a regimen that's going to
help me with my weight management, with
my brain health, with my anti-cancer
health and my detox.
How many things do I need to buy?" It
gets confusing. You want your You want
your daily minerals with doc. You want
those. you want your 90 essential
minerals and
you'll get them with your 90 for life um
products, but you're going to get them
maybe once a day. We now know that we
need to eat throughout the day. So maybe
take your pollen burst in the morning,
your 90 minerals in the afternoon, and
maybe some pollen tabs at night because
you need to eat three times a day,
right?
and our our body needs micro minerals
and micronutrition three times a day or
you start crashing, blood sugar's
crashing, you're eating more, you're
tired, you can't focus. I notice for me,
I used to be able to skip meals all the
time. Go, go, go. Drink my polymers. No
problem. But now at 62, I feel like I
need to eat meals more. I need to not
skip my meals, but I know that I have my
burst with me
and that evens it out. And then of
course, we didn't even talk about the
energy. Everyone's losing energy and
it's because they're not getting
nourished. So, stop all your energy
drinks with tons and tons of caffeine
and gining and all this stuff. Oliver
has a little bit of caffeine in it, but
that's not why you're having energy for
10 hours.
Anyone who can give you 10 energy energy
for 10 hours without a craft,
that's not caffeine. That's pollen.
That's eating the perfect meal. And it's
not only feeding you for 10 hours. It is
feeding your brain. It's the only
so-called energy nutrition drink that
gives people mental clarity. Everyone
talks about that. The first thing people
say to me is, "Wow, I have a clean
energy all day. I feel good and I feel
like I'm focusing better." You're not
going to be focusing better on some of
these crazy nutrition drinks that are in
aluminum cans or plastic bottles or lots
of sugars or lots of artificial sugars.
Um, every day I'm on this planet, I find
another artificial sugar that isn't good
for you.
Stevia and regular sugar are good for
you. They're they're natural foods, but
a lot of these other weird sugars, every
every day there's another study coming
out. Um, pure coconut water is great. I
don't like coconut water, but I could
tell you that if I mix it in with a
polymer burst, it'd be more palatable
for me. Um, just as a caution, don't put
too many things in your pollen burst
because it might make it taste bad. And
the the claim to fame for polymer versus
is flavor. And I know that sounds silly,
but you have customers who are going to
shoot you down. You have you need
compliance.
It doesn't matter if we have the best
products in the world if no one's
drinking them. We need compliance.
Pollen the pollen line is so easy to
comply because number one, it doesn't
offend you on the way in. It doesn't
offend you on the way out.
And it's easy and it feels good and
that's what you need. This is not a
difficult detox. Like I said, a lot of
people, a lot of your customers may not
want to do this really complicated
detox. They'll do this. And it's not
your fault. It's that our world is busy.
We're tired. We don't want to do a lot
of stuff. We can't remember. Everybody
can remember to take two liver tabs
twice a day. Everyone can remember to
take a couple fish oils with each meal.
Everybody can remember to drink a burp
in the morning. And if you need a second
one, you'll know. If you drink a polymer
and by two o'clock you're really tired,
then you might need a second one. Or if
you do a second one and it keeps you up
at night, do half of a packet or take
your pollen pad. They're caffeine-free.
That's what I do. I do my drink in the
morning and my tabs in the afternoon. I
am very sensitive to caffeine. And
you'll have people as they age get very
sensitive to caffeine. Don't let them
get scared off the caffeine and pollen
burst. There is a synergistic effect of
the SOD, the pollen, all the
micronutrients, and a little bit of
caffeine, and you don't get jittery. If
it's someone's first time, have them
drink a 16 bottle of the burst over an
hour or two. You don't want to give
someone a burst, stick it in a 4 oz
glass of water, and shoot it down. They
will have a detox reaction and that
usually feels like heart racing.
Then they say, "Oh, too much caffeine."
No, you drank the burst too quickly.
You've never had SOD before. I mean,
it's in your body, but it's dropped over
the years. You're probably dirty with
toxins and you just got this big gift
all at once. So, anybody who's brand
new, tell them to drink the packet over
30 minutes, sip it, put it in 16 ounces
of water, they should be fine. Um, Mary
has her hand raised, but how do I Go
ahead, Mary. I know you've had your hand
raised for a bit.
>> Yes. Hi, Adrien. How are you?
>> Hi. Good.
>> Good. Good. Well, just so you know, my
family is a fan of pollen burst. We have
it every day. And I got to tell you, we
do like to mix and match pollen burst
different flavors. So, it just it
definitely gives you a different flavor
profile.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, couple of questions. one is uh we
also have the daily liver uh tabs and a
question for uh about this product is um
I I know I've taken one and that was
plenty.
Um sometimes I've taken two but how many
liver tabs maximum can you take per day?
So, new person who may have a buildup of
toxins, I always say to just take one
pill twice a day and not at night just
in case when your body's working on
removing toxins, it usually does it at
night when you're sleeping and it could
keep you awake. So, anybody who already
has sleep issues,
>> keep the keep the liver tabs during the
day because that's when your body does
most of this cleanup and the liver tabs
might make someone like be awake a
little bit more at night. Nothing bad
would happen. Um you these these pills
will tell you how many you need. If you
are taking four a day and you still feel
tired or sluggish and your liver enzymes
are still a little high, go to six a
day.
>> You can't overdose on it. If you start
having loose bowels, then I back down a
little bit. The only thing that can
cause loose bowels is the aloe,
>> but your but most people tend toward
constipation and this product can
actually help them with that. And we
know that part of your detox pathway is
moving your bowels. So, it's another
gift that the liver tabs give people.
But I always say start slow. Start with
one pill a day and after three days, go
to two. If your customers tasting metal
in their mouth, breaking out, or
smelling like a strange body odor, or
just feeling super tired, stay at that
dosage until those feelings go away.
>> Then up at one.
>> Yeah. I take four. I take four a day,
but when my um when I moved into my new
home and I had my painter come and
repaint my front door, I was taking six
a day.
So, you can add when you have toxins or
when you go to the dentist or if you
have a colonoscopy and go under, you
know, anesthesia, it's always great to
have those extras,
the extra tabs.
>> Got it. Perfect. Perfect. And then this
the second question is on the polymer
burst tabs. Um the question is is this a
so it says I think one tablet at least
on the directions it says one tablet. Is
that like a one forone exchange for the
packet of colverse or how do you how do
you view that?
>> No the closest you can get is drink a
cup of green tea and take two tabs. But
even if you do that, it's just not the
same as the burst. We've tried. Everyone
has tried to hack this.
>> Okay.
>> But um I would say if someone can't do
the burst, um find out what the reason
is. You can do half a burst. They could
take half a burst in a couple tabs.
You can interchange them. You can't
overdose on it. I've taken eight of
these at one time if I broke my toe. You
know, you get it's anti-inflammatory.
You cannot overdose on the pollen. Um,
so if someone is having trouble, if
they're sensitive to gluten, there is a
microscopic amount of gluten in the
packets but not in the tabs. And most
people that I've experienced with with
either sensitivities to gluten or just
don't want to have gluten, they're
totally fine on the pollen burst.
>> So it's a micron, it's like a micron
away from being able to put on the label
gluten-free.
So if someone has celiac,
I would say maybe stay away from it. You
know, be careful. If someone is not
sure, they can certainly make the drink
and just take a few sips of it, see how
they feel. Um I know we've worked with
people before with Crohn's disease
>> who love the polymers because it helps
two things. Um inflammation because that
Crohn's caused a lot of inflam and it
feeds you. I mean, imagine that nutrient
sheet that Ruth Ellen put up earlier.
Imagine a Crohn's patient getting micro
food so they don't even have to digest
it. Soaks right into their bowel. Easy
peasy. And um we've had, you know, good
success with that. But always check with
your doctor. Go slow. Experiment with
it. Um
it's all about taking the inflammation
out of your body and feeding it deeply.
>> Got it. Got it. Well, I must say that
I've taken the polymer burst tabs when I
was driving and I may have felt a little
tired. So, I've taken the tab and it's
actually given me enough energy to kind
of keep driving. So, so that's a nice
use for it where you don't want to
necessarily drink a lot while you're on
the road and taking the pollen burst tab
was a good feature.
>> Absolutely. And matter of fact, um
Dr. Corey when he would do his iron man
races he would only drink one burst
maybe maybe two in an 18hour race and he
relied on these and these little pills
right in his shorts and that's what a
lot of athletes do because they're
trying to not do as much drinking. We
have a lot of truck drivers,
long-distance drivers. We have a lot of
paramedics who or emergency room nurses
and doctors who love the mental clarity
they get from these pollen tabs. I have
people with ADD and ADHD who love
it gives them that clarity.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
we've been using this for ADD, ADHD for
decades.
>> Um and even the burst drink.
>> Uh so it depends if some people who have
focus issues and do well with caffeine,
it calms them,
the burst drink is perfect. For those
who have too much hyperactivity and need
to control their uh their excite
excitability, the tabs are great.
So, it's mix and match. Um and uh we
also have
which I didn't have time to talk about
today. We also have male and female
hormonal products that are a different
type of pollen al together. I'll only do
a quick shout out. Proof and Prostat are
a completely different blend of pollen
that are fat soluble. And the Proofam is
amazing for anyone from age 10 to age
90. It morphs with the body. Whatever
your body is missing hormonally, it
fills it right in. It's amazing. I mean,
imagine that picture Ruth Allen put on
the screen. All those nutrients, but
different fat soluble. So, it really
helps to balance hormones. Prostat is
probably one of the best prostate
remedies in the world and in in uh in
Asia. This was a prescription for the
treatment of enlarged prostate and it
was by prescription. In the United
States, holistic medicine doesn't have a
script. I mean, I wish they'd go there
one day, but um this stuff's amazing for
all men and it's non-toxic. It doesn't
interfere with medications. And that's
what I'm going to end with is that the
pollen extracts is
um
really
goofproof.
A lot of other products, whether it's
female or male, have multiple
ingredients. What do we have these days?
We have millions of customers who are on
10 different medications. It It's hard
to navigate being a nutrition consultant
in this day and age when you're worried
about what's going to react to what. But
when you're doing a pure pollen, it
doesn't interfere with medication
because it's too little amount of
everything. And a lot of people, if they
do like a female hormone product that
has like nine different things in it and
they react, they don't know what they're
reacting to. But if they're just taking
pollen, that's it. They know. Um, and
same thing with the prostat. The
prostat, if a male is taking five, I'm
on five different medications. Can I
take this? most likely. I mean, always
say check with your doctor, but it's
just rye pollen. That's it. It's food,
so it shouldn't like interact. And so,
you know, we always say check with your
doctor. We don't want to have somebody
blow up on us, but um it's really
helpful to have a product that is just
one ingredient.
>> Yes. Yes. Um I have a couple more
questions if you don't mind, Ruth Ellen.
Um let me just do two quick questions.
one and I know you'll have this how
pollen burst is harvested
uh is one and the um impact with
lympadeema
lympadema
>> I think
>> but which is I think water retention I'm
not a physician
>> probably so yeah
>> so so you know that's water retention a
lot of times is unfortunately this
happened to me in my life um with my
late husband
is when your liver stops working,
it's responsible helping balance water
in your body.
So, liver tabs would be really important
if that's what's happening. If this
person's doctor is saying, "Yeah, you're
getting swelling or you're getting
buildup of water, we can give you a
water pill, but why is that happening?"
>> If it's the liver that's sluggish, we
got to get on those liver tabs.
And the other question about the
harvesting, um, a remote part of
southern Sweden, an organic flower farm.
Can't get better than that.
>> Perfect. Thank you, Ruth Ellen. Over to
you.
>> Thank you.
Thank you, Mary. Appreciate you so much.
Okay, I have a couple questions um as
well, and I know you have a hard stop,
so um I have three questions for you.
Um, two are from Brenda Teresa.
Um, she's here on Zoom and she would
like to know if all of the ingredients
that we showed are also in the liver
tabs.
>> Are all the ingredients that we showed
are also in the liver tabs? Yes, they
are.
>> Okay. I thought so, but I wanted And
then can perform
Prof, I'm sorry, Prof be used by someone
71 plus years of age? Oh, yes. And
>> you can use it till you die, right?
>> Yeah. If you're post If you're
postmenopausal like I am, it's going to
focus on your bladder. It's going to
focus on skin. It's going to focus on
just connective tissue. It's going to
focus on the things that you need in
that time frame. So, yeah.
>> So, it doesn't focus on the hormones.
>> It it does it keeps it it keeps a good
balance of the hormones. It'll help you.
Um, but it actually does a lot more. It
does what it needs to do. If you are
feeling great uh with your incontinence,
bladder issues, UTI, then you will be
fine. You'll it'll work other places.
It's it's smart. It knows where to go.
That's why a 10-year-old girl who's
getting her period for the first time
and there's it's swinging back and forth
or a 40-year-old woman who has excessive
heavy periods, it'll it'll all calm it
all down. It work. It's so It's so
wonderful. Okay. So, it doesn't
specifically stimulate the hormones. It
just balances.
>> It balances them out. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, somebody who's been told by
their doctor because they had a C nasty
thing that was hormone based, they could
still take that.
>> Yes. They will not put estrogen in their
body. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. Perfect. Perfect. And
then I have a compliment for you.
This is a pretty big compliment.
There is somebody on Rumble who wants to
know how to get a hold of you so that
you can be a guest on their podcast.
Okay. Um it's a pretty big compliment.
You can write to me at my email which is
adrien
ad ry
gytraining.com.
>> Okay, perfect. So, absolutely reach out
and I'll be uh happy to assist if I can.
Uh, wonderful. Thank you.
>> You're welcome. All right.
I know you have a hard stop and it's
3:56 my time. So, um, thank you so much
for joining us today and I'm sorry about
the difficulty earlier.
>> Thank you. Thank you. You saved the day
and you might say I might call on you
later to save me to figure out what we
did to get here. I I would love to help
you with that if we totally just Yeah,
>> I'm here for you.
>> So, if I get my co-host to join us on
the screen, then we're gonna just go
ahead and close out um the show. And um
again, if you have to leave before I'm
done talking and it's saying whatever,
just feel free to just log out of Zoom,
okay? Just do
>> Thank you. Appreciate it.
>> Thank you so much. Very, very much.
>> Thank you so much. love to love to be
on. No problem. Thanks.
>> Thank you so much.
All right, everybody. Thank you so much
for joining us and I want to thank
everyone who hung in there and waited.
Thank you for your patience. I hope it
was I feel like it was well worth the
wait. I um thank you for doing that.
Uh, so I'm going to go ahead and say a
couple things and I'm going to introduce
the people that have helped this show go
today. Um, first of all, if you have
questions, you can email us at questions
dailywithdoc.com
and um, please include your phone number
so that we can contact you because
sometimes for some reason some emails
don't accept our email. I don't know why
but um that way at least somebody can
contact you if you know you send a
second email and say where's my response
and we could call you. Um, also
this program was for intent uh was
intended for educational purposes only,
not meant to treat, diagnose, or cure
any diseases or
anything that we shouldn't be saying. So
long, it's crazy. But we just want to
help give you content so that you can
make decisions on what is good for you
and maybe learn something that you
didn't know, which I think we did a lot
today. Um, also if you need to talk to a
certified holistic health coach, please
call us at 8559493377.
And so today we had on with us AJ who's
our digital marketing director who had
to step off early. So thank you for all
that you do AJ. And then we have Sherry
who is part of our tech crew who also
helped with the gatekeeping of the door
today. So letting people in and keeping
an eye on that. So, thank you so much
Sherry and Mary who is out there on the
different platforms and bringing
questions in and also checking keeping
an eye on stuff as well. So, thank you
Mary for all that you do. And then we
have Marilyn, Miss Speedy Fingers, who
is
amazing typist. I don't know how you do
that. So, thank you for all that you do
and we appreciate you very very much.
and also we had Rod out on the different
platforms um
bringing some stuff in as well. So,
thank you everyone for all that you do.
And a big shout out to Becca Dukes. We
love you. And also everyone, always
remember to be kind. You don't know what
somebody's going through and um the
world needs more kindness. That's that's
just a fact.
Thank you all for joining us today and
um we will see you tomorrow with
pharmacist Ben Fuches for pharmacist
Friday. Have a great day everyone. Thank
you so much.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science and Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.